Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Rohan Oza,
the branding guru
behind some of the world's most
successful consumer products
joins the tank.
You want ideas on how to build
brands? I have that.
‐Yes!
‐Whoo!
But let's take a ride
in my time machine, shall we?
Don't make me
look at that.
This maybe
isn't the best fit.
I'm clearly being a jerk.
This is a really hot space.
Look, we can't give
straight answers.
I think I have to
go with my gut here.
‐So, I read your mind.
‐Dude, that's a great offer.
Wait, don't answer that.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the tank
is a business that helps
find love in a unique way.
♪♪
Hi.
My name's Brendan Alper,
and I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
I'm seeking $200,000 for a
5% stake in my company Hater ‐‐
the only company
in the world
that can make love
using the power of hate.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, Sharks, I know most
of you aren't single anymore,
but let's take a ride
in my time machine, shall we?
[ Laughs ]
‐Stud!
‐Mark, what is that?!
‐What a stud. What a stud.
‐Look at the mullet.
‐That is so good‐looking.
‐He's so pretty.
Oza: That jaw line ‐‐
so powerful, Mark.
Mark, picture this.
It's the year 1990,
and you're on a...
mediocre first date.
It's going okay.
You're talking.
You both like your jobs.
You both like sports.
Boring.
But then
you start talking about
how much you hate
basketball referees.
How would you feel
about that?
I never had a bad date,
but I get your point.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Ha‐ha.
Ooh!
When it comes to dating,
hating always gets overlooked.
But there are
studies that show
that people who hate
the same things
actually form closer bonds
than people
who love the same things.
Very interesting point.
Yeah.
And that's why
I invented Hater ‐‐
the dating app that matches you
based on what you hate.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐That's great.
‐That's very clever.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐Want to see how it works?
‐Yes, sir.
Okay. Now, Rohan, you're
today's lucky bachelor, okay?
Okay!
We're gonna try
to find you love through hate.
But the other Sharks
get to play along, too.
Here you go.
‐Okay.
‐One for each.
‐Thank you.
‐Ah!
‐I love a game. Nice.
‐This is great!
‐There you go.
Thank you!
Greiner: So we're gonna play
"Hate this or like this," right?
‐This is fun.
‐Here's how it works.
I'm gonna show you topics
on the screen,
and you have to say whether
you love or hate them.
And the we can find
your perfect match, okay?
‐Okay, good.
‐All right, so,
staying in on a Friday night.
I'm okay.
I'm okay with that.
People who only eat organic.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
All right, selfies.
‐Selfies.
Mr. Wonderful.
[ All groan ]
No question.
He's not here to defend himself.
That's not fair.
All right, now we're gonna find
your perfect match.
Ready?
[ Laughter ]
Ohh, Barbara!
All right!
‐Bingo!
‐Let's do this.
Right under your nose
the whole time.
Uh‐oh, uh‐oh! Whoop!
[ Laughter ]
I've always wanted
a short rich man.
[ Laughs ]
See how well it works?
So, here we have Barbara,
and we can see all
of the things that she hates.
So everything that she swiped
on, you get to see,
and everything you've swiped on,
she gets to see.
That's pretty cool.
That's great insight
going into a date.
‐Cool.
‐It's really interesting.
So, you download the app,
and then you start throwing
questions at me
like you threw to us.
‐Exactly. Hop right into it.
And I swipe left
or swipe right, or...?
That's right.
There's five different options.
You can hate, love,
dislike, like, or neutral.
The key to this is acquisition,
right?
So, how many people
are on this app?
So, we launched around
Valentine's Day of this year,
and we already have
over half a million people.
And what's your biggest
concentration in any one city?
It's New York and Oslo
are actually tied.
Together: Oslo?
So, how are you
making money?
The app is free right now,
and it's early.
Mm‐hmm.
We started ‐‐
But how do you plan
to make money?
So, we ‐‐ we're testing out
a few different ways,
but the most interesting part
is actually the data here.
So, let's say you wanted to
advertise one of your products.
We could slide it in
as a topic,
and not only can we tell you
who loves your product,
what demographics hate it,
we can also tell you,
"People who love your product
also love these flavors
or hate these celebrities."
‐But you have no sales today.
‐Zero sales.
‐No sales?
That's correct.
But you have
a $4 million valuation.
‐Yes.
‐Got it.
Typical app.
So you say ‐‐
How did you come up with this,
Brandon?
I got to know.
Right out of college,
I‐I needed some money,
so I went to go work
on Wall Street.
I stuck it out for six years,
and I hated it.
And I finally worked up
the courage to quit
and become a comedy writer.
And Hater was originally
a comedy‐sketch idea that I had.
But the more I thought about it,
the more I thought,
"I actually think
there's a demand for this.
I think people would use this
if we could make a product
that was as good as the idea."
And so that was
about two years ago.
I set off on the journey,
and here I am today.
Wow.
But how do you support yourself
doing this new business?
So, up until this point,
I have not paid myself a salary.
I liquidated my 401(k).
I cashed all my life savings
from Wall Street.
‐Wow.
‐You're all‐in, aren't you?
I'm all‐in.
How much have you raised
in total?
We raised 500k.
We just closed
on the investment.
What?!
‐Yeah.
‐Wow.
From a very exciting investor,
as well.
It's the founders of King,
the mobile gaming company.
How much equity
do they get for that?
They get 12.5%.
So, it was $3.5 million
free money,
and then after the money,
we're now at $4 million.
‐How did they find you?
‐So, I knew that the only way
that we were gonna
get market saturation
if we made a big splash
right away.
So one of the first guys
that I hired was a PR guy.
And for months, we just worked
on crafting this story,
making the pitch,
and sending it
to as many reporters
as we could.
And within a few days, we had
hundreds of thousands of people.
‐Wow.
‐What's your daily active users?
Daily active users ‐‐
closer to 8,000 to 10,000.
Okay, so that's
why you're here 'cause that's ‐‐
that's not
anywhere near enough
for people
to really get dates from it.
Exactly.
What makes these things
successful
is density
in the marketplace.
So tell me about
how many people in New York
and what the engagement and
ongoing consumer interaction is.
In New York,
that's our number‐one city.
We have
tens of thousands of users.
In terms of daily active,
I think we have
a few thousand every day.
So, as the only one
on this panel
who's actually not married,
you know,
I may use these apps,
and my biggest need
would be options.
Sure.
And I think that
from your numbers,
what I'm lacking is
the sheer density of people.
Yeah.
So from my experiences,
maybe just take that money and
really drive hard in two cities.
Right.
Because, you know,
there's enough population
in New York City alone.
Right.
Then there's
a whole buzz around it.
When you start spreading
yourself too thin,
then there's just
not enough in each market.
From my level of expertise,
I‐I prefer a more dense
user base in a particular city
'cause then I can see
what the interactions are,
and then
I'd be jumping in.
As much as I love you,
I'm out.
Okay.
The name is pure genius
'cause it's contrary.
And your upside‐down heart
I love, okay?
I believe
it's a constant press hook.
And you happen to live
in New York City ‐‐
the press capital
of the world.
How convenient.
So I'm gonna offer you
$250,000 for 5%.
More than you're asking.
‐Ooh.
‐And I want you to answer me now
because
I'm clearly being a jerk
offering you
more than you're asking for.
Wow.
Is that a take‐it‐or‐leave‐it
exploding offer?
You're saying I don't get to
hear from anyone else?
‐Yes, that's what she's saying.
‐It goes away if he says no.
‐Boom!
‐If anyone wants to jump in
right now,
now would be the time.
Dude,
that's a great offer.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Now would be the time.
‐She gave you more money!
‐Wow, listen.
I would take it
in a heartbeat and run.
I‐I also like Hater.
Though, I'm sorry,
I got to come in and ‐‐
and be a hater
and disrupt this.
But I really like it, but I like
it for a much bigger reason.
I think
that we could take the app far,
but I also see Hater
as could become a brand.
‐Yeah.
‐Like a big brand.
I could see Hater products.
‐Haterade, maybe?
‐I could see Haterade.
‐[ Laughs ]
Haterade!
Now we're struck.
We don't like beverages.
Too expensive.
It get ‐‐ It gets my mind going
because this is what excites me.
This is what I do.
Is this an offer, Lori,
or is this a chitchat?
So I'm gonna make you
an offer.
My offer is going to be
the $200,000 for 10%.
I'm off the table!
Really?
You're taking it off the table?
Together: Five, four, three...
‐Oh, my God!
‐You're gonna lose her!
‐...two...
‐Barbara, wait!
‐...one!
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Brendan has two offers
on the table
from Lori and Barbara
for his dating app Hater.
But Barbara may pull her offer
if Brendan doesn't
decide immediately.
She's gonna ‐‐
You're gonna lose her!
Wow!
‐...two...
‐You're gonna lose her!
‐Barbara, wait!
‐...one!
Nope! Off the table!
So, you know,
I'm not going to be
somebody who hands you off
to an assistant of mine.
I'm gonna be somebody
who actually sits with you,
brainstorms, works,
figures it out together.
You're gonna get me.
You're gonna get my time.
You're gonna get
that personal Shark
holding your hand
all along the way.
That is so exciting.
Now let's talk business.
‐Ay, ay, ay.
You either have to get big
or go home. Right?
‐I'm unhappy.
‐Because none of your brands ‐‐
I'm with Barbara.
None of your brands
are gonna give you any money...
‐Ay, ay, ay.
‐...unless you have
a big enough user base.
Would you agree with that?
‐I would agree with that.
‐Okay.
So, in order
to get to those places,
you have to have visible
celebrity influencer‐type people
that use the app.
And then on top of that,
I love the gaming aspect.
That's why King came in to you,
right?
Because that's
something different.
They're looking for new
platforms that can accelerate.
That's why they invested,
correct?
Mm‐hmm. Exactly.
‐Is there an offer?
‐So we're on the s‐‐
So we're all on the same page
so far, right?
‐We're on the same page.
‐Are you giving an offer?
Oza: Is there an offer
in this thing?
Is there an offer here?
So, what ‐‐ Let me tell you
what I can do before I ‐‐
So there's a ‐‐
There's a lesson.
A lesson.
Go, Mark.
No, so, what I can do is
obviously celebrities, right,
whether they play for the Mavs,
throughout the NBA,
actors, whatever.
I'll give you the $200,000,
but I want 7.5%, plus I want
2.5% in advisory shares.
That's easy.
‐So he's sort of matching me.
‐So ‐‐ So similar deal.
‐Same deal.
‐But he really sold the farm.
Same deal as Lori.
And you're gonna save money
in going out
and getting the influencers.
And he'd like to have me
in on the deal with him.
No.
Brendan, what's your answer
to Mark's offer?
I ‐‐ My answer is I would like
to hear from Robert.
Okay, so you're not sold
on my offer?
Oza: Ooh!
By the time you're done
with him, I may not be here.
Make it exploding.
Brendan, love it.
Hate the idea
of making it wider right now.
It's all about density.
Mark's long preamble is right.
You got to get out there.
Kids are gonna love to play it.
I have to tell you
the PR angle from this is huge.
But I think you're gonna need
a little more money.
I think you either ‐‐
you have to run faster,
do events
in a couple of cities.
I'd start
with New York and LA.
And I actually think
the person that would be really
good with you on this
is Barbara.
I love working with her.
Here's my offer.
I'll also give you $250,000,
with Barbara,
if she'll come along, for 15%.
So $500,000 for 15%.
$250,000 from Barbara,
$250,000 from me.
Let's blow this thing up.
I would go in for the $500,000
with Robert for the 15%.
I'm torn because I want to work
with all of you.
‐We can ‐‐
‐Brendan, the thing I'll add ‐‐
You'd have to spend money
for the influencers.
for the parties
with the celebrities.
That's gonna be a cost,
even with King involved.
That won't be a cost
with me involved.
And that's the difference.
So, what are you gonna do,
Brendan?
[ Sighs ]
The one thing I've learned
with founders,
and the biggest mistake
they make
is not taking
enough money in.
I'll leave you
with that.
That is true.
[ Sighs ]
Take the money.
I think I have to go
with my gut here.
♪♪
I'm gonna go with Mark.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Whoa!
This is amazing.
This is brilliant. Great choice.
I don't ‐‐
I don't love it anymore.
Thank you.
‐Boo!
‐Appreciate that. Thank you.
‐Ay!
‐We'll have so much fun.
Thanks, Brendan.
This is right up my alley.
Alper: Going in,
I really wanted Mark.
I just know he has experience
in the technology space,
and he has the connections
that can really
take Hater to the next level.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 8,
Ariel and Ben Zvaifler
landed a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for their subscription service
for puppies ‐‐ PupBox.
I believe in you guys.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
Since "Shark Tank," the business
has really taken off.
You guys are so cute!
To celebrate our success,
we decided to host our
first ever PupBox adoption day.
Ariel:
And we have partnered with
the Helen Woodward Animal Center
to co‐host the event.
They adopt out over 4,000
puppies every year,
and we hope that the 12 they
brought today will get adopted.
Smile!
We even have celebri‐puppies
from social media
ready to give kisses.
Every puppy
that's adopted today
will get
a free PupBox subscription.
‐Hi!
‐Hey, how are you?
‐Who's this?
‐PupBox is a monthly delivery.
We send both training
information and products
to help walk new puppy owners
through puppyhood.
In the year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $250,000 in sales.
Since our deal nine months ago,
we've done $700,000 in sales.
We used
Robert's investment
to develop
our own line of products.
We now have a PupBox leash,
a puppy‐training tote bag,
and several toys
featured in the box.
We just launched our new
puppy‐training content platform.
It provides new puppy owners
tips and tricks customized
for their puppy's age.
We're gonna complete
some paperwork
and get you
all ready to go.
The event
has been a huge hit.
Some of the puppies
have already been adopted,
and most importantly,
we're raising awareness
for an awesome cause.
We're so grateful
for "Shark Tank" and for Robert
for making events like this
possible for us
and for really putting our brand
on the map.
Our long‐term goal
is to become the go‐to brand
for everything puppy.
All: Puppies!
[ Ukulele playing ]
♪ Life can be a tough nut
to crack ♪
♪ Coco Taps
will get you right on track ♪
♪ Great taste ♪
‐Wow!
‐♪ Less waste, too ♪
♪ Coconut water
just flows right through ♪
♪ And it's gotta be fresh,
right from the tree ♪
♪ Fresher than fresh
is the best way to be ♪
[ Chuckles ]
♪ No mess,
and no stress, too ♪
♪ Gotta tap your thirst,
coco dreams come true ♪
Coco Taps. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
‐Good job.
‐Aloha, Sharks!
All: Aloha!
My name is Coco Vinny.
I'm from Long Beach,
California,
and I'm the founder and chief
coconut in charge at Coco Taps.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I'm asking for $150,000
for 10%
of soon‐to‐be our company.
Close your eyes for a minute
and imagine we're on our very
own Hawaiian coconut plantation.
Ahh.
The sun is shining.
The birds are singing.
You feel that ocean breeze
on your skin.
And what's even better
is you've got a fresh‐tapped
coconut in your hands.
Now, Coco Rey‐Rey and I ‐‐ We're
gonna get you all tapped in.
Come on, Coco Rey‐Rey.
Aloha.
Whoo!
Now, Coco Ro, here you go.
Lovely.
Thank you, buddy.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Coco Lo‐Lo!
‐Coco Lo‐Lo.
‐Coco Lo‐Lo and Coco Ro‐Ro.
‐This is Coco B.
‐Here. Cheers.
‐Thank you, darling.
‐Salut.
‐Coco Ro.
‐Wow.
‐Oh! Wow!
Now, Sharks,
drinking coconut water
out of plastic bottles
and cans
tastes old and stale.
I'm sure
now that you're tapped in,
we can all agree that drinking
fresh, right from the source
is the best way
to relax and hydrate.
You know, we've all seen some
crazy ways to open a coconut.
Banging! And hammering!
And chopping!
You could lose a finger.
We've even seen
some of these crazy tools
pitched right here
in the Tank.
But what we've created
is the only 100% made in USA
coconut water system.
It allows you to quickly
and safely tap a coconut.
Let me just show you
how it works.
You take the Coco Tapper,
you remove the safety cover,
and you make a hole right
in the coconut like so.
Now, once a hole
is in the coconut,
you take the Coco Tap and you
thread it in counterclockwise.
Now, the end of the Coco Tapper
is like a wrench.
And you just tighten it on
like so.
Now, once the tap is secured
into the coconut,
it's fully re‐sealable.
Our lab results show
that the fresh‐tapped coconut
will last up to four weeks
in the refrigerator.
Now, Sharks, our mission
is to get everyone tapped in to
this ultimate vacation beverage.
All you got to do is say,
"Yes!"
and we'll start bringing in
boatloads of coco cash.
What are your sales?
In our first year,
we did almost a quarter million
dollars in revenue, and ‐‐
How long ago was that?
That was
just January of 2016.
In 2017, we're trending
double for where we are last ‐‐
for where we were ‐‐
‐What's the product?
Is it just a tap?
Wait, Robert.
Robert, Robert, Robert.
We sell
two products currently.
We have a do‐it‐yourself
tap kit,
and we have the branded
tapped beverage line,
which is in over 20 resorts
on the Las Vegas strip.
Got it. It's a tap kit
and a finished coconut drink.
Yes.
‐Yes.
‐And how does it break out?
Is it 50‐50?
So, right now
our current sales
are 80% tap‐branded beverage
and 20% kit.
So you're selling
a self‐contained coconut drink.
How often do you have to go
around the Las Vegas strip
delivering to the 20 resorts?
So, we're delivering daily.
So, we have, you know,
major corporations ‐‐
Caesars, MGM Mirage,
Cosmopolitan, Wynn, Encore.
How much do you charge
for them, Coco Vinny?
A case ‐‐ our costs ‐‐
tapped, branded, everything,
ready to deliver ‐‐ $27.
And then
what are you selling it for?
$45 per case right now.
Okay, how many cases
do you typically deliver
to a resort at one time?
A minimum order
is 5 to 10 cases.
So you're making $90 or $180
per customer per delivery.
Yes, sir.
So, tell us
about your background.
Why did you
come up with this?
So, I'm a 6'5" Mexican Jew
standing in front of you today.
Nice!
[ Laughter ]
Isn't everybody?
I'm a problem solver.
I‐I‐I started solving problems
when I'm really young.
Really, I was a fat kid
in the very beginning.
I was challenged
with my weight.
And I overcame that.
I lost 75 pounds.
‐Good for you. Congrats.
‐Good for you.
So, basically, an Indonesian
friend of mine said, "Try this,"
and I was like,
"I don't like coconut water,"
and he said, "Just try it."
Once I was tapped in,
it was over.
Hammer and knife every time
after my workouts.
I broke my stepdad's knife.
I said, "We got to fix this."
So I made the coconut
re‐sealable,
created the tool kit.
Took me a year and a half, R&D,
patents, manufacturing,
made in USA, beat China
on their price ‐‐ everything.
I see a massive
untapped market.
The cruise industry ‐‐
60% of their revenue
of 24 million passengers a year
are drinking.
‐On a ‐‐ On a cruise ship?
‐60% ‐‐
Vinny, that's not the challenge,
right?
The challenge is you're
a delivery service, right?
You've got to deal
with the logistics of delivery.
How do you scale that?
We invented a whole high‐volume
production system
that we set up in California
and Nevada already,
and we're literally five minutes
from the casinos.
Vinny, I'm not worried about
the production issue.
Greiner: Producing it ‐‐
When you say ‐‐
How do you get
to more resorts?
Not just Vegas, but the rest
of America, somewhere else.
They're calling us already.
From all over the world,
they're starting to call us.
They love
this tapping system.
Wait, hold on.
Let‐‐ Let's be clear
'cause this is a critical point
in this entire discussion.
The resorts are calling you for
the fully completed coconut...
Yes.
...or they're calling you
for the taps?
Yes.
Okay, I'm lost.
So, hang on.
Did you create the tap
to help the coconut business,
or do you see that as ‐‐
To me, it's almost
two separate businesses.
So, that is ‐‐
The tap business ‐‐
The reason why it's only 20%
of our ‐‐ of our sales
is because we just let that
organically live
on Amazon right now.
But, Coco Lori,
with your help...
[ Laughs ]
...we would do an infomercial,
rock the world on it...
Ah!
Corcoran: Oh, that's
what you had in mind.
...show them how to tap
a coconut in another business.
‐Okay.
It's a coco cleanse.
It's where we send them
the coconuts and everything.
Coco cleanse?
You're gonna drop‐ship
the coconut?
Three‐day coco cleanse.
It works. I've done it.
There's lots of business
here.
Now, with your help, Coco B,
you've done some
amazing franchises.
Franchises?
The Coco ‐‐ The Coco Taps Shack
model will work.
‐You have another business?
‐Oh, this is another business.
There's three phases
to this entire coco dream
that we're building.
Phase one ‐‐
ultimate vacation beverage.
Look, Vinny, we can't
get straight answers.
‐Wow.
‐I can't tell if you can scale.
I'm sorry that you feel
that way.
I'm out.
Coco love.
Vinny, there's a term ‐‐
you're drowning
in opportunity.
Every time I took a sip of my
coconut, it was a new business.
I can't follow
the bouncing coconut.
I'm out.
Wow. Okay.
Well, coco love.
Corcoran: I think this
is a complicated business
with a really skinny margin.
Although, I think this
is a cute, little product
that could sell a lot.
But the truth of the matter is
it's way, way too early,
and I don't believe
in that product.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Greiner: Here's my thought ‐‐
I understand the love of
the coconut and all of that.
The problem is it's so niche.
If I invested in this,
I'd be coco‐nuts.
Okay.
I'm out.
I'm sorry you don't get it.
I think that you have actually
a fantastic‐tasting product
because the coconut water
in this thing is terrific.
You have a wealth
of opportunities,
but what you have to do
is focus.
During the pitch, I didn't
get the clarity of focus,
and I didn't get the clarity
of the game plan operationally,
and unfortunately ‐‐
Do I hear ‐‐ Time out.
Do you want to
just hear the ‐‐
I'm out, brother.
Coco love to you.
Thank you, guys.
Congratulations
on what you've accomplished.
‐Coco love, Coco Vinny.
‐Thank you. You know what?
‐Good luck.
‐I'm on my way out.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Life can be a tough nut
to crack ♪
♪ Coco Taps
will get you right on track ♪
‐Bye, Coco Rey‐Rey.
‐See ya, Coco Rey‐Rey.
♪ Great taste,
less waste, too ♪
♪ Coconut water
from a Mexican Jew ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ And it's gotta be fresh,
right from the tree ♪
♪ Freshly fresh
is the best way to be ♪
♪ No mess,
and no stress, too ♪
♪ Gotta tap your thirst,
coco dreams come true ♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank is a way to
take control of your healthcare.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Julia Cheek,
and I'm from Austin, Texas.
My company is EverlyWell,
and I'm seeking $1 million
in exchange for 5% equity.
‐Whoo!
‐Good for you!
EverlyWell is transforming
lab testing,
a $25 billion market,
to be simple, convenient,
and useful for you.
I started EverlyWell because
I had a really common problem.
I spent months
trying to figure out
a very basic hormone imbalance.
I went to a lot of doctors
who ran a lot of tests,
which took a lot of time
and cost me a lot of money
in unexpected lab bills.
All I received was a bunch
of this paper with numbers,
which I spent weeks researching
on my own with no help.
I thought there had to be
a better way.
And that's why we built
EverlyWell.
EverlyWell provides convenient
at‐home lab tests
with results you can actually
understand and use.
The process is simple.
Purchase a kit on our website,
where we have everything
from food intolerance
to metabolism testing.
Collect your sample
at your convenience at home,
and send it back
to one of our certified
and accurate partner labs.
Board‐certified physicians
review and approve your results,
and in just a few days, you get
your results in your inbox
and online
on our secure platform.
You'll find easy‐to‐read graphs,
custom content,
and a community of support.
No more wasting time
in waiting rooms.
No more guessing
how much your test will cost.
And no more wondering
about your results.
So, Sharks, who wants to test
the waters with EverlyWell?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Let's do ‐‐
I'd like to test
my cholesterol right now.
Can you do it right ‐‐
Not in real time.
‐No, it requires a lab, yeah.
‐Here you go. Vitamin D.
Vitamin D,
and I'm deficient in that.
Food sensitivity, Lori.
You like to cook.
‐Thank you.
Men's health for Mark.
Cholesterol
'cause you like to run, Barbara.
‐Mine's nice and low.
‐Good heart health.
‐I know that.
‐Sleep and stress
for adrenaline
from racing cars.
‐Thank you, Julia.
‐Thank you.
Walk us through
an average test.
Let's ‐‐ Let's look at
Rohan's test.
Does he send a blood sample?
What does he send?
Okay, do I pee?
What do I do here?
With the Vitamin D test, it is a
small finger‐prick blood sample.
About half of our tests
require a small finger prick.
Half of them don't.
How do I get the test?
I go to your website.
So, currently,
we have 13 different tests,
all available
only on our website today.
How much do they cost?
They range from anywhere
from $69 to $399.
How much cheaper is that
than going to the doctor?
It's generally cheaper
to use our tests.
For example ‐‐
‐By 10%, 50%?
It very much depends
on your insurance.
So, Julia,
it's not covered by insurance.
Today we entered the market
to get traction
by being cash‐pay‐only.
We are not in network
with insurance providers yet.
So what you're really selling to
me ‐‐ It's really convenience.
I can get the test done quickly.
I don't have to go anywhere.
Our customers tell us
the value proposition is access,
not just convenience.
The reason
we started the product
is 'cause people cannot actually
get these tests on their own.
They also aren't able to know
the price of the test
before they go to the lab
to the get blood taken
or provide a saliva sample.
They get hit with a lab bill.
Have you proven this out?
Do you have revenue?
Do you have consumers?
We launched
in beta last summer.
In less than a year, we have
sold $2.5 million of product.
Wow.
And we're on
a $400,000‐a‐month run rate.
We've grown 20% on average
month over month.
‐Good for you.
‐That's very good.
And you're projected
to do what?
So, the forecast today
is $5 million, $5.5 million
based on our online business
without the genomics launch
next month, which is happening.
Sales this year
are $5 million.
Yes.
Next year?
$12.3 million.
So we do expect next year
to be able to double through
the genomics combined products.
Tell us something about
yourself.
We don't know
your background.
Actually, I come from
a fairly traditional background.
I grew up in Dallas.
Got, actually, a full academic
scholarship to Vanderbilt.
‐Wow.
‐Graduated early
with a double major in econ
and psychology.
Ended up in consulting
and actually went back
to get my MBA from Harvard,
where I graduated top 5% there,
as well.
‐That makes sense.
‐Wow.
You're not a doctor, Julia,
right?
I'm not a doctor.
You must have raised
a lot of money.
I raised $5 million to date.
‐Wow.
‐At what valuation?
The last round
was the convertible note
at a $15 million cap.
What's your burn rate today,
Julia?
Our burn rate right now
is about $150,000 a month.
You're losing money today
on this.
We are losing money,
but it's 'cause
we're investing
for building
additional features.
If we were to cut down
the head count and say, "Okay,
are we just gonna grow
organically?"
we could do that
with our margins today.
It's just not
where we want to go.
Now, we do have one test
that we just launched,
which is already 10% of our
business, which is our STD test.
‐I was gonna ask you that.
‐You're missing STD
in a big way there.
‐I'm like...
That, honestly, will end up
being your number‐one seller.
Is there online competitors
like you?
There is no online competitor
doing a platform
of at‐home kits.
What about a company
like 23andMe?
Could they just not pivot?
What's the competitive
advantage?
We believe our competitive
advantage is the platform.
Of our six labs, we can actually
roll out 250 different tests,
and next month, we are launching
a partnership with Helix
to actually bring in
genomics products.
So you can get
any type of health data,
whether it's genetic,
whether it's lab,
and add it into the system.
So there are people that'll give
you certain specific tests,
but you're doing
the entire range of them.
Exactly. Right.
Are you looking to sell
to something like 23andMe?
And what's your goal?
‐So, yeah, so, our ‐‐
our customers are 75% women,
and ‐‐ and really,
women are going to be ‐‐
They're 80% of the
healthcare decision makers.
‐75% are women?
‐It was higher.
It was 85% before
we launched our STD product.
Because women
are managing everything.
They're the ones
that need to save the time.
And to the exit question,
this is a really hot space.
There is a lot of opportunity
both for acquisition
from either traditional
diagnostics companies
or from genomics companies.
Julia, your challenge
is competition.
It is a race right now. It's
gonna take a lot more money.
There's gonna be a ton
of competition in this space.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
I think what scares me
about your business
is I think it's gonna take
constant re‐development,
and you're gonna need
a lot of money
that I'm not wiling
to give.
So I'm out.
The cost of doing business
in America
for employees on healthcare
is astounding.
Mm‐hmm.
When I compare it to my UK costs
or my Canadian costs...
Mm‐hmm.
...it's unbelievable.
Four, five times as much
on a per‐employee basis.
As Mark said, it's a race.
And you got to raise more money.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
I've seen a number
of presentations.
I have to say yours
is probably right there
at the top
in terms of poise...
Thank you.
...intellect,
sophistication.
I also think that taking charge
of your personal health...
Mm‐hmm.
...is a massive trend because
we want to know what's going on,
but you don't want to go
to the hospital.
Right.
But this is
a highly expensive game.
I think the $1 million that ‐‐
that I'm happy to give you
would be diluted rapidly
because this is gonna take
tens of millions
to get
to the promised land.
So for that reason,
unfortunately, I'm out.
I think the product
is brilliantly crafted.
‐Thank you.
‐It's really nice.
It's really easy.
It's super‐clear.
I think the state of healthcare
in our country right now
is so precarious.
Millions right now
are out of insurance...
Yes.
...or fearing
that they will be.
And I think that this gives
people an empowered way
at least to check
on some things
to know whether or not
they have to go find a doctor.
And I totally get
the woman thing.
I would like to take
a flier on you.
So I'm gonna be
a little creative here.
Cheek: Okay.
How about I give you
a $1 million line of credit,
8% interest for the 5%.
And then I'll bring
all the marketing savvy
and the retail and everything
that I know I can do.
We actually desperately
need a line of credit.
‐Oh!
‐As you know,
our inventory
isn't very expensive,
and we don't have enough history
to have collateral from a bank.
And so while I didn't bring that
up today,
it was something that
I'm very interested in.
‐So I read your mind.
‐You did.
Well, then...?
So, I know that I'm technically
supposed to counter.
But I...
‐You're allowed to say yes.
But I would love to do a deal
with you, Lori...
‐Whoo!
‐...if you want to do it.
‐Whoa!
‐Thank you!
‐Outstanding!
‐Yay!
‐Well done, Julia.
‐It's so exciting!
‐Wow!
‐Thank you so much. I love it.
It'll be great
to work with you.
I love it.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's so smart.
‐Congratulations, Julia.
‐Thank you all very much.
‐You were fantastic. Congrats.
‐I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yay! I'm so excited!
Lori has the knowledge
of how to think about branding.
We have a great team
of investors,
but there's something about
being able to understand
how to sell products to our
consumer base, which is women.
And she's gonna be
so helpful in doing that.
‐Let's just take this example.
‐This could be huge.
Let's say you're in college.
You're sexually active.
Just for that test alone,
think how many students
and young people and whatever
it would help out.
Just college campuses.
I agree with you.
It's huge.
Unmarried people
it would help out.
Narrator: Next up is a healthier
way to start your morning.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Ashley Thompson.
And I'm Kat Thomas.
We're the creators of Mush
out of San Diego, California.
And we're here on a mission
to combat America's
love affair with sugar.
We're here to offer you a
10% equity stake in our company
in exchange for $300,000.
So, when Ashley and I first
entered the workforce
in the world of finance,
we quickly realized
how genuinely hard it is
to find foods that are healthy
as well as convenient.
As you Sharks know,
most on‐the‐go breakfast foods
and snacks like yogurt,
protein bars, cereal ‐‐
They're all completely laden
with sugar
and other
processed garbage.
That's why we created
this bad boy ‐‐ Mush.
First to market, all natural,
100% ready‐to‐eat oatmeal.
Now, the really cool thing
about this product
is it's never
actually cooked.
What we do
is we cold‐soak the oats
in house‐made almond
or coconut milk.
Resulting product
has a beautiful consistency
of a pudding,
is just as easy to digest
as traditional oatmeal,
but it's
more nutrient‐dense.
We haven't cooked off all those
awesome vitamins and minerals.
Mush is also dairy‐free,
protein‐rich, high in fiber,
and it's served
conveniently cold
in these amazing six‐ounce
single‐serving pods
for grab‐and‐go
convenience.
They even come with a little
white spoon underneath the lid.
Da‐da‐da‐da!
[ Laughs ]
So all you have to do
is pop the top,
peel off the seal,
and enjoy.
Now, Mush is so much more than
a healthy, convenient oatmeal.
It's honestly
fuel for your body
and fuel for a revolution
in the food industry.
Sharks, we don't know
how else to cut it to you.
We're [bleep] fed up
with the food industry.
So, please, for the health
and well‐being of this country,
join us in combating America's
love affair with sugar.
Now, who's ready to Mush it
to the limit?
‐I'm ready.
‐Let's try it!
‐I'll try some Mush!
‐Yeah!
‐I'd like some mush!
‐Is it "moosh," or is it "mush"?
‐It's either way.
‐Oh, the whole thing is for me.
Thomas: So, we're gonna start
from right to left.
On your right,
you'll see vanilla bean.
That's the original flavor.
What we have there
is a rolled oat
soaked in
our house‐made almond milk.
We then add
an organic vanilla bean.
Oh, wow!
Sweeten it with a degla date
out of Coachella, California,
a touch of sea salt,
and that's it.
Exactly.
‐All right, dark? They're ‐‐
Dark cacao.
It's an organic cacao powder.
The benefit of that is it's
incredibly high in antioxidants,
considered a Mayan super food.
‐It's great.
‐Yeah, so, some people ‐‐
‐It's delicious.
'Cause there's a bitter ‐‐
a bitter earthiness to it.
‐Great. This is fantastic.
‐Michigan blueberry.
We use a wild blueberry
out of Michigan.
Has a much more tart,
sweet profile.
And then the last
is a cold brew.
You're actually getting
your caffeine
and your breakfast
all in one.
You've got date
and then a touch of sea salt.
Oza:
Product is fantastic.
You guys have
definitely delivered
on the trend
of where things are going.
Sugar is public enemy
number one.
You have fiber in here.
You have protein in here.
All the good stuff.
Tell us about the sales.
Exactly that.
‐Okay, great.
So, we started the company
two years ago.
Our first year we just sold
the product at farmers markets
to get feedback.
We did $70,000 in sales
our first year.
This year
we've done $120,000.
We've launched in Whole Foods
in March.
And the number
for next year?
We're set to make $900,000
for the year.
‐Wow!
‐All right,
what do you make it for?
What does it retail for?
Sure.
So,
depending on the flavor,
we make it
for about 70 to 80 cents.
What's the retail?
The retail's $3.99.
Your margins are terrific.
But your price point
seems out of whack
with some of the competitors
that I've seen out there.
‐Okay.
‐I disagree.
I don't ‐‐ I don't think
the price point's too high.
Okay.
I think for the value
you provide,
the convenience you provide,
the challenge
is where you're selling it.
If you're completely dependent
on grocery stores,
then he's right ‐‐
You have to be concerned.
But you have
such a convenience factor
and the fact that Amazon
is taking over the world,
I mean, there's a reason
why Amazon bought Whole Foods.
Jeff Bezos believes that pricing
and speed of delivery
are the two things that will
never go out of style,
and so his goal is that
they can get groceries to you
faster than you can
get in the car
and go to the grocery store
and back.
Where Mark is wrong is that
price point does matter
'cause there's a price point
that's been set ‐‐
When you're in a case ‐‐
When you're in a case
next to your competition.
But even online,
yogurts have set a price point,
whether we like it or not.
They're $1.99.
Can I throw out a random idea?
‐Sure.
I think that,
just very tactical,
you might have
too big of baggage.
There might be
too much in here.
I think you can drop
cost of goods...
Thompson: Sure.
...and then it also bridges
the snack realm...
Sure.
...where I'm not
fully making this a meal.
‐Yes.
‐Tell us about you.
What's your background?
How do you know each other?
So, I got a job at Goldman
in London.
When I looked around
the trading floor
and I looked at the very few
women that there were
and I really
didn't find anyone
that I would aspire to be
one day.
Mm.
And so I was like, "Okay,
this maybe isn't the best fit."
Ashley, tell me about you.
So, I went to school
in New York City,
graduated in three years
with a mathematics
and economics degree,
and then went on
to Goldman.
‐Did you like that job?
‐Unlike Kat, I loved my job.
All right, how did you come up
with the Mush thing together?
So, we were
just, like, talking,
kind of bouncing ideas
off of one another,
and I was like, "Yeah,
I'm itching to do something,
but we don't really know
what to do."
And the one thing
that we connected on
was how hard it was to fuel
ourselves at the desk.
Hmm.
And so we quit our jobs
and moved to San Diego.
‐And got to work.
‐And then we got to work.
So, guys, I love the mission.
I love your purpose.
But I hate the food business
because it requires
so much money.
Not for me. I'm out.
‐Well, we appreciate that.
‐Thank you so much.
Thanks so much.
So, ladies,
I respect my venerable Sharks.
Don't get me wrong.
But none of them have been
part of building $4 billion...
Cuban: But there's one exception
to that, right?
...consumer
food‐beverage company.
‐Let him talk.
‐Well, no, no, no.
‐You're mischaracterizing.
‐Let him talk.
He'll be
the first to admit.
That's not a fair thing
to say at all.
It's okay.
Let him speak.
No, it's not a fair thing
to say.
No, 'cause
there's a difference
between
being an entrepreneur
and having been
through the grind
and having had your back
against the wall
versus walking in and saying,
"50 Cent, here's $10 million
and equity in a company
that I don't own."
Just so we understand here,
I've never been an entrepreneur.
Mark's right.
What I have done
is found brilliant founders
with amazing products
and turned them into
multi‐billion‐dollar exits.
You don't need another
entrepreneur.
You need someone
with ideas.
And I disagree with Mark.
Isn't that the same thing?
No, Mark.
I agree with Mark.
Amazon is the way of the future.
But today this is not
gonna fly off on Amazon.
No, that's not what I said,
though.
You've got to get ‐‐
That's not what I said.
You've got to get
Whole Foods...
What I said
was the world has changed.
Let him finish.
You've got to get Whole Foods
nation‐wide.
I have that.
‐So do I.
You want to get into
traditional grocery?
I have that.
‐So do I.
You want ideas on how
to build brands? I have that.
So do I.
‐So do I.
‐Mark has all of that,
and he's not got a single food
or beverage company
that has exited
over $100 million.
Marketing, connections.
And I'll give you six
if you want, and rock and roll.
Is there an offer?
For me, the juice
has to be worth the squeeze.
There's got to be enough
equity in this thing,
and you'll need more money,
so what I want to do
is offer you guys ‐‐
instead of $300,000,
I'm gonna offer you $400,000
for 20% of the company.
Ooh!
You guys are brilliant
mathematics people.
You worked at Goldman.
It's simply 5%.
Okay,
we're at the point ‐‐
‐We're talking about is 5%...
‐Each.
...worth getting a decent exit
or getting a mega exit.
You know, Rohan is genius
with the food industry.
He's done SmartWater
and Vitaminwater and popchips.
He could really blow you up.
So I will step out.
Cuban:
Okay, so, wait, wait, wait.
I'll make you the offer
with $300,000 for 10%,
just what you asked for.
‐Wow.
And an unlimited credit line.
Whatever you need.
Wait, don't answer that.
Don't answer it.
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Kat and Ashley
have two offers
for their cold oatmeal product,
Mush.
Rohan has offered $400,000
for a 20% stake.
Mark's offer is $300,000
for a 10% stake
plus
an unlimited credit line.
What do you guys say?
Wait, don't answer that.
Whether you have Mark
or Rohan or I,
the entire future
of your business is dependent
on the strength of the people
you choose from the get‐go.
You fit my team
of entrepreneurs perfectly.
You're cut out of the same cloth
as my winners.
Here's my offer.
I'll give you the $300,000 cash
for 10% of the business.
I'll give you whatever credit
lines you need
'cause the food space
is expensive.
So, guys,
what are you gonna do?
Cuban:
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let me just give one more
example.
My company
Alyssa's Healthy Cookies.
Same ‐‐ Same concept,
same approach ‐‐ no sugar.
Very similar to you.
‐How big is that market?
‐$8 million in sales.
‐$8 million.
$4 million in profits.
Chef's Cut is my smallest one ‐‐
$60 million.
No, but the difference is,
right,
how much money do they make?
‐Chef's?
They're about 5 million bucks
a year.
‐Okay, so, that company ‐‐
‐Valuation's over $200 million.
So, how about your biggest ‐‐
popchips?
Valuation
is all that matters.
No, the valuation only matters
if you plan on selling.
They want
to change the world.
Do you plan on selling
this company at some point?
No, we want
to change the world.
Change the world.
All right.
So my partner Doug makes
$4 million in profits a year,
and he's just putting
all this in his pocket.
We've gotten offers.
We've turned them down.
Now, I've pushed Doug
to scale more.
Doug doesn't want to go any
faster than he wants to go.
You guys could have done that
in your sleep.
Can we make this popchips
or Vitaminwater?
Or can we make it
Alyssa's Cookies.
That's the difference.
You know what,
he's exactly right.
He's exactly right.
‐You want to make a br‐‐
Because his beef jerky
company ‐‐
You want to make it
a mega brand across America.
That's what changes the world,
if you want to change the world.
Yeah, popchips changed the world
in ways we can't imagine.
[ Laughter ]
‐Distribution ‐‐
‐This is what I do for a living.
If you want to do enterprise
software, he's your guy.
Rohan, you're gonna have
a heart attack.
Herjavec:
What are you gonna do?
They're all, honestly,
unbelievable offers,
and we're, like, incredibly
humbled as entrepreneurs.
It's, like, honestly
a kid's dream.
Mark, we'd love to.
‐Ay, ay, ay!
‐Aah!
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
‐You're so welcome.
‐Thank you for everyone.
Thompson:
While all of the offers
from the Sharks were amazing,
we went with Mark because
we want to change the world
for the better, and so does he.
Rohan, you got a little bit
scraped in that one.
What did you learn
out of that?
Honestly, I felt, given my
expertise in this industry,
that...
‐You were worth more than Mark.
...my equity should have been
worth more.
I think for where they are
and where they want to go,
I think he had a better vision
for them.
I don't disagree.
♪♪